as you can see I'm locked down in a room
that's full of books and I know what
most of them are but a few weeks ago I
discovered the book I didn't realize I
had and there was something really quite
exciting about it I found this book
which is called introduction to chemical
philosophy found it quite late at night
and then I looked inside and much to my
surprise I found signature that appeared
to be from Ernest Rutherford the famous
physicist I was amazed usually when you
find these things they're some sort of
forgery or joke but I was really excited
photographed it and sent it off to Keith
Moore the hero of Brady's objectivity
channel who's an expert on things like
this and he emailed back and said he
thought it was genuine where did this
book come from professor how come you've
got it I have two theories where it
might have come from I certainly didn't
buy it myself and one theory is that I
may have inherited it from my friend
David Jones who left me his whole
library books and I just selected a few
in a big hurry
and I probably chose this one because
it's by Tilden who's quite a famous 19th
century chemist I probably just took it
without looking inside the other
possibility is that it was inherited
from my wife's family because her
grandfather was a student with
Rutherford and I suppose it's possible
that Rutherford thought this is no book
I don't know what to do with it I'll
give it to one of my students professor
from the signature it appears that he's
written his name to say I own this book
he's not autographing it for a fan or
something I totally agree this is not a
dedication to somebody this is a thing
to show you own it when I got the book
out so we could make this video I
noticed
surprisingly there is a second signature
of Rutherford inside the cover where you
can barely read it now this book was
published in 1886 when Brad Rutherford
was 15 and my theory is that perhaps he
bought it secondhand when he came as a
student to England he was born in New
Zealand because there are a couple of
prices written in pencil which is the
signature of a secondhand book dealer
and probably he wrote his name on the
inside cover and thought nobody will see
it there so he wrote it on the next page
as well perhaps we should tell people
who owned as Rutherford was and secondly
is that book worth a lot of money earned
this Rutherford was the famous physicist
who formulated the first plausible
structure of the atom and discovered
that alpha particles were the nuclei of
helium atoms he won the Nobel Prize for
chemistry in to 1908 and eleven of his
students also won Nobel prizes shows how
little all of us have achieved I don't
think the work is worth very much at all
though Keith Moore when he saw the
signature and the fact that the book is
also written by a fellow of the Royal
Society is keen to have it from the
library of the Royal Society when I've
got fed up with it whoa whoa hang on a
second I might make you an offer I'd
quite like that one maybe we should have
a bidding war other thing which I
think's interesting is that this book
contains a really quite old periodic
table this periodic table is there
filled by followed the oldest periodic
table that I possess and if you look at
it they're also two strange things it's
covered in question marks where they
might be new elements of course they're
no noble gases because they hadn't been
discovered but beryllium is shown with
the GE because sometimes in those days
people called it glue singham from
Greek word meaning sweet beryllium salts
are really poisonous but somehow people
tasted it and decided it tasted sweet
and then boron which I've never seen
before is written as Bo and rhodium as
ro I suspect they put the periodic table
in into terrific hurry and they made
some mistakes
professor just while you were talking I
I was doing a bit of googling and I
found an autographed letter signed by
Rutherford from 1920 selling for two and
a half thousand dollars my feeling is
that when it's a letter that's something
really special when it's just labeling a
book just like he might've labeled his
clothes for the laundry then it probably
isn't quite as exciting but it's a book
that's got the periodic table in it and
as we all know
Rutherford's name is on the periodic
table yes though it wasn't plain of
course no but I think I have no idea
whether it's worth much money and but
it's a very nice feeling that I may be
reading a book that rather for great
isn't it a great thought as well to
think about Rutherford having a book and
looking at that periodic table not
knowing that one day his name would be
honor yes
of course that's the you assumed that he
actually read the book right and and
that the periodic table seems to have
been just added as an extra chapter at
the end are you going to give the book
to cake at the Royal Society probably
eventually it could end up on
objectivity in a second video but the
other thing which is quite I think is
interesting there are a whole series of
questions about the periodic table and I
can't answer most of them they're so
old-fashioned questions like to explain
the differences between sodium and
potassium and I have no idea what in 89
somebody would have expected for an
ounce of that question since there no
answers in the book we'll never know
take me through the very moment when you
first opened it and saw a Rutherford I
was in my in the study just about to go
to bed so it was after 11 o'clock at
night and for some reason I was just
looking at the books and I opened this
and I thought wow
but of course my first thought was that
it was probably a forgery or whatever
though I don't see why anybody should
put Rutherford's name in a slightly
obscure chemistry textbook if you're
going to forge it you would Forge it
somewhere else
I also found in another room here this
book here which has a photo of
Rutherford with his signature I mean
this is a printed signature what's
interesting is by the time we got this
signature he'd become a lord so he wrote
Rutherford without an e because there's
a convention in the UK that people who
are Lords then all men who Lord's saying
just their title Rutherford because he
was Lord Rutherford without the first
name thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video I think it's a really good
chance you'll enjoy my other YouTube
channel objectivity it's all about all
sorts of famous science objects and
little stories from history I'll put a
link here on the screen and down in the
video description we are joined by
Captain disillusion and guess what today
it's happening because this is where
they store most of the moon rocks and
soil that we'll brought back from the
moon
the Apollo astronauts joined by Diana
Cowan from the physics girl YouTube
channel it's the work gloves of destiny
I didn't tell you who was operating the
camera because it's not James James who
normally does it he's back in the UK
it's a very special celebrity camera
operator actually